[Musique]
à la suite des opérations de recherche
des victimes des cismes en Turquie et en
Syrie des sapeurs sauveteurs et des
sapeurs-pompiers des Yvelines se sont
rendus ce matin au kogique le centre
opérationnel de gestion
interministérielle des crises ils ont
été reçus par le directeur général de la
Sécurité civile pour un retour
d'expérience
suite au révélations liée à la vente aux
enchères des meubles du château de
Grignan le procureur général a saisi la
Cour des comptes en vue de l'ouverture
d'une instruction contentieuse il
décidera si la faire fera l'objet d'un
classement ou d'un renvoi devant la
chambre du contentieux
en sport arthurin darknech le joueur de
tennis originaire de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye a perdu ce mardi 6
3 6 4 contre le joueur Leandro riez dit
au premier tour du tournoi de Marseille
il retombe donc à la 72e place mondiale
ce mercredi 22 février marque la journée
mondiale du scoutisme le département des
Yvelines compte 20000 scouts ce qui en
fait le département numéro 1 en France
tout mouvement confondu parmi les villes
où on trouve le plus d'effectif
Saint-Germain-en-Laye Versailles
Rambouillet et Montfort-l'Amaury
jusqu'au 21 avril les apprentis du
cfa-cma 78 de Versailles propose une
coupe gratuite aux étudiants et aux
personnels de l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines l'objectif
permettre aux apprentis de travailler
sur clientèle et prestations se
déroulent sous le contrôle d'un
professeur
[Musique]